S
HAPPENING ON THE SAME DAY.
>> Tucker: OH, SO IT'S CARACAS
NOW, AND WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
ASK ANYONE WHO OWNS A BUSINESS
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES.
IN BEVERLY HILLS EVEN.
IT'S COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
THE REASON IT IS IS BECAUSE
POLICE AREN'T PUNISHING PEOPLE
THE WAY THEY DID.
IN NEW YORK CITY, A MAN WAS
BUSTED WITH 20,000 FENTANYL
PILLS IN CHELSEA, WHICH WAS A
NICE NEIGHBORHOOD IN NEW YORK,
RELEASED IMMEDIATELY.
THE SO THIS DOESN'T WORK.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DOES WORK.
ONE OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE WE'VE
IN THE LAST YEAR IS JEANNIE
BURTON, 50, A MOTHER OF THREE.
FOR MOST OF HER LIFE SHE WAS
BADLY ADDICTED TO DRUGS.
WHILE ADDICTED, SHE COMMITTED A
SLEW OF CRIMES, CAR THEFTS, SHOT
SOMEBODY.
SHE RACKED UP 17 SEPARATE FELONY
CONVICTIONS AND SERVED THREE
SEPARATE TERMS IN PRISON, AND
THEN DID SOMETHING THAT TOO MANY
DO, SHE GOT TOTAL CONTROL OF HER
LIFE, EVEN GRADUATED COLLEGE.
IN THE PROCESS OF THAT, GAINED A
LOT OF WISDOM.
SO IT'S WITH GREAT PLEASURE WE
WELCOME JENNY BURTON TO THE SHOW
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOU'VE SEEN THIS FROM BOTH SIDES
AS A DRUG ADDICTED PERSON
COMMITTING CRIMES AND
CLEAR-THINKING PERSON ASSESSING
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THE COUNTRY.
WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING
DIFFERENT, DO YOU THINK?
>> INCARCERATING WITH INTENTION,
TUCKER, WHICH THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DEFINITELY NOT
ADDRESSING ANY OF THE NECESSARY
COMPONENTS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR SOCIETY RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE USING A HARM REDUCTION
APPROACH, NOT JUST TO DRUGS, BUT
ALSO TO CRIME.
THAT'S EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC.
>> Tucker: SO YOU SAY
INCARCERATION WITH INTENTION.
THE IDEA IS IF YOU PUT SOMEONE
BEHIND BARS IT'S CRUEL, YOU'RE
THE CRIMINAL FOR WANTING TO DO
THAT, AND YOU'RE SAYING, HAVING
BEEN IN PRISON THREE SEPARATE
TIMES, KIT BE GOOD, NOT JUST FOR
SOCIETY, BUT FOR THE PERSON
INCARCERATED.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
>> EXACTLY WHAT I'M SAYING.
WHEN WE INCARCERATE WITH
INTENTION, WE'RE SEEING A
DECLINE IN HUMANITY.
THE UNITED STATES IS LEADING THE
WAY WITH THAT, TAKING A HARM
REDUCTION APPROACH EVERYWHERE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS, WE'RE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS AND A DECREASE IN
INCARCERATATION, BUT WHEN WE
INCARCERATION WITH INTENTION,
WHAT WE WOULD BE DOING IS
IMPLEMENTING SERVICES DURING
INCARCERATION THAT HELP PEOPLE
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THEIR OWN
LIVES.
WHAT THIS WOULD ALSO DO, CREATE
MORE OF A SAF-T-NET IN THE
COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED, IMPACTED BY THOSE
COMMITTING CRIMES, WHICH I WANT
TO SAY THAT PROBABLY I WOULD SAY
OF 90% OF PEOPLE IN ACTIVE
ADDICTION COMMIT CRIMES.
THOSE COMMITTING CRIMES ARE ALSO
USING DRUGS AND ALCOHOL.
THESE UNDERLYING CAUSES WOULD BE
ADDRESSED VERY INTENTIONALLY SO
WE MAKE SURE WE'RE ATTACKING THE
PROBLEMS WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE
SEPARATED FROM THE DESTRUCTIVE
PATH, IF THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> Tucker: ADDICTION MEANS
CRIME, NOT JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE
BREAKING A LAW BY USING DRUGS,
BUT YOU'RE DRIVEN TO CRIME.
DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD HAVE EVER
GOTTEN BETTER AS A DRUG ADDICT
IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
INCARCERATED?
>> NO.
I'M EXTREMELY GRATEFUL THAT
INCARCERATION WAS AN OPTION FOR
ME.
IF I WAS USING TODAY, WITH THE
POLICIES IN PLACE RIGHT NOW, I
WOULDN'T BE WHERE I AM.
WE'RE DENYING PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY THRIVE
AND TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT MY OWN
APPEARANCE IS THAT I DIDN'T HAVE
THE NECESSARY SKILLS TO NAVIGATE
SOCIETY.
IF NOT FOR THAT SEPARATION, I
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCUMULATE THE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF SERVICES THAT I DID IN ORDER
TO GET ME WHERE I AM TODAY.
WE DID A LOT, A LOT OF INTEL
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF DECADES,
SINCE THE FAMOUS 1994 CRIME
BILL, WHICH WAS AUTHORED BY JOE
BIDEN, IN CASE PEOPLE THAT DON'T
KNOW, THAT EXACERBATED
INCARCERATION IN THIS NATION,
AND PULLED SERVICES OUT OF OUR
SYSTEMS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION AT
THIS POINT OF WHAT IS NEEDED,
BUT WE'RE DENYING PEOPLE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
WE WENT FROM ONE END OF THE
PENDULUM ALL THE WAY OVER TO
THIS OTHER SIDE.
HARM REDUCTION IS INACTION.
INACTION IS ACTUALLY AN ACTION.
WHAT IT IS IS SENDING A MESSAGE
THAT NO LIVES MATTER IN THIS
NATION.
>> Tucker: HARM REDUCTION IS AN
ACTION, INACTION SENDS THE
MESSAGE THAT NO LIVES MATTER.
I HOPE PEOPLE ARE HEARING YOU,
THAT YOU GET A CHANCE TO GET
YOUR VOICE OUT THERE.
I THINK